you push back your album a week uh
dolphin and and uh you know obviously
everyone who signed the dolph put out
the long-lived golf project out of
respect to dolph
you guys are from the same city
um
what was your guys's relationship like
i'm not saying i'm like i've seen them
two times but it wasn't never
a relationship that was just built like
you know i could call on him right call
on me but at the end of the day was
mutual respect you know always it wasn't
never anything but at the end of the day
when i was younger i looked up to a lot
of these people like you know the yo
gotti's i looked up to young dog if i
looked up to both of them two counts
because at the end of the day review
from memphis it's like who you gonna
sign to if you blow it right now you're
gonna sound double got it that's like
the talk and i looked up to what they
model was how they did things and when i
blew up instead of signing either one i
said you know what i stayed in the past
yeah so now i got my own labels they
inspired you to just
yeah cause you stayed indy you could
assign to anybody yeah for real that's
big um what just being from memphis what
did dolph mean to the city like that's a
that's a really serious loss man um
independence most more than anything i
know from my standpoint because this on
my mom teach i'm saying anything anybody
that teach with my mom preaching what i
was brought up on
i rock with so independence and and at
the end of the day family you know i
feel like he had he had like two or
three kids he had a he had a girl i'm
saying a family person so when stuff
like that happen i don't even think
about the person i think about the
family and the kids you know that's
where it hit home and that's where he
hit most hit 100
um
are you are you still in memphis or yeah
i live in memphis but if i'm not in
memphis i'm out here a lot of the time
but i like to create that balance
because there's certain things i want to
implement in my city and i feel like if
i'm out of touch with my surroundings at
a city i won't really know what the city
needs